coronavirus reaches the US president
Trump is playing it down Democrats are
playing it up and no one can tell if
this is much ado about nothing or if
we're all gonna die we will examine the
mass media generated hysteria then
speaking of not knowing whether you're
alive or dead Joe Biden's presidential
campaign gets some good pole news out of
South Carolina two different kinds of
Republicans are voting for Bernie
Sanders
and finally the mailbag on Michal
Knowles and this is the Michal Knowles
show
[Music]
coronavirus has reached the u.s. we now
have one confirmed case and nobody knows
what to think about this is this the end
of the world or is this not such a big
deal
the first case in the u.s. is in Solano
County California so that's in Northern
California by San Francisco and
Sacramento that area the scary thing is
we have no idea how this individual got
coronavirus this person did not recently
travel to a foreign country this person
did not recently have contact with
someone who is known to have had the
virus so that is rightly freaking a lot
of people a plus it's spreading around
the world so you've got people under
quarantine in New York you've got half
of Italy's regions now infected by this
the markets are tanking if you are
invested in the stock market this is not
a very good day and so President Trump
first of all is trying to assure
everybody that everything is just fine
he's trying to downplay all of this now
obviously that's what he would do the
question is is it real or is it not as
this a huge deal is this not a huge deal
President Trump says that the reason
everybody's freaking out is because the
Democrats are exploiting this and
creating a panic for political advantage
I think speaker Pelosi's incompetent
she lost the Congress once I think she's
gonna lose it again she lifted my poll
numbers up 10 points I never thought
that I would see that so quickly and so
easily I'm leading everybody we're doing
great I don't want to do it that way
it's almost unfair if you think about it
but I think she's incompetent and I
think she's not thinking about the
country and instead of making a
statement like that where I've been
beating her routinely
at everything instead of making a
statement like that she should be saying
we have to work together because we have
a big problem potentially and maybe it's
going to be a very little problem I hope
that it's going to be a very little
problem she's trying to create a panic
and there's no reason to panic because
we have done so good all they're trying
to do is get a political advantage
this isn't about political advantage
we're all trying to do the right thing I
love the president Trump takes about 40
solid seconds of just insulting Nancy
Pelosi before he gets to the actual
question of whether coronavirus is a
huge deal
still I tend to agree with what
President Trump is saying here that the
Democrats and the mainstream media but I
repeat myself are using this as an
opportunity to create a panic for
political advantage I say this without
looking at any of the science without
looking at any of the studies or at
least not very many of the studies about
this I say this simply because of the
hysterical response that we've seen from
the left and the media great example of
this is in that same press conference
where a president from goes out there he
says he's going to address the
coronavirus issue he says that he's now
appointing a task force the task force
is going to be run by no less an
authority than the Vice President of the
United States right so it shows he's
really taking this seriously
and the left Hillary's him for it
immediately blue checkmark Twitter
actually accused Mike Pence of spreading
HIV
here's president Trump's announcement
when Mike was Governor Mike Pence of
Indiana they've established great health
care they have a great system there
system that a lot of a lot of the other
states have really looked to and change
their systems they wanted to base it on
the Indiana system he's very good and I
think and he's really very expert at the
field and what I've done is I'm going to
be announcing exactly right now that I'm
gonna be putting our vice-president Mike
Pence in charge
okay perfectly fine statement to make is
obviously doing that to show that the
administration is taking this seriously
and the left I kid you not is freaking
out because they say Mike Pence spread
HIV and AIDS throughout all of Indiana
how are they even making that argument
we'll get to that in a second first I
got to thank our friends over at
LifeLock tax season is upon us my
friends during tax season your name your
social security number a lot of valuable
information about you can be floating
around the internet more than usual
maybe you're emailing it that
information can end up getting sold on
the dark web you can lose your identity
you can have it stolen that's why you've
got to call LifeLock the number one most
recognized brand in identity theft
protection
LifeLock monitors for uses of your
personal info it alerts you to possible
suspicious activity and this is most
important if you become a victim of
identity theft a dedicated identity
restoration specialist will work to fix
it nobody can prevent all identity theft
or monitor all transactions but having a
life lock means one less thing to worry
about this tax season wouldn't that be
nice join now and save up to 25% off
your first year just go to life lock
calm slash Knowles Cana wles that's life
lock calm slash Knowles for 25 percent
off
how on earth can you accuse Mike Pence
of spreading aids throughout Indiana how
do you take the most kind of basic
statement of hey look we're taking this
really seriously
the vice president is going to be
overseeing it how do you take that into
we're gonna spread coronavirus like Mike
Pence spread AIDS so they got this idea
they've got this argument by twit
stinger a vote by twisting a political
position so beyond anything that's
recognizable that all you can do is
laugh at them Mike Pence when he was
governor of Indiana opposed a very
liberal and stupid policy called needle
exchanges needle exchanges are when you
encourage heroin addicts to shoot up
more drugs because you give them the
needles so that they can shoot them up
this has been tried in a lot of cities
around America it always spreads disease
it always spreads crime
it increases addiction it's disgusting I
mean the reason that you when you're
walking around certain cities like San
Francisco for instance and you see
needles on the streets because the
government is just giving them to
junkies it's a horrible horrible
indefensible policy right so Mike Pence
like most other conservatives says yeah
it's a pretty bad policy I'm not going
to support that and what the left did is
they said okay well if you don't support
giving needles to junkies then you are
personally responsible for the opioid
crisis you're responsible for heroin
addicts shooting up and when they share
needles if one of them has HIV and it
goes to the other one you are
responsible for that
next they're gonna accuse him of killing
Freddie Mercury it doesn't make any
sense at all and yet that is the degree
of mass hysteria mass media hysteria
that the left and the blue checkmarks
and the usual suspects are willing to go
to so next in this press conference
already I'm pretty skeptical of the left
here because they're willing to twist
anything next President Trump is asked
why he's treating coronavirus
differently than he felt Ebola should
have been treated in 2014 total joke to
appoint someone to lead the Ebola
response with quote zero experience in
the medical field
now you look they listen to a lot of
what I had just listened to a lot well
because there's a much different problem
than Ebola Ebola you disintegrate it
especially at the beginning they've made
a lot of progress now on Ebola but with
Ebola we were talking about it before
you disintegrated you got Ebola that was
it this one is different much different
this is a flu this is like a flu and
this is a much different situation than
of all
he's right it is different I mean the
imagery that Trump uses is often so
vivid that it creates sort of disturbing
images in your mind but it's true with
Ebola you did disintegrate you did melt
basically I mean there's a truly
horrifying condition with coronavirus
it's different growing virus is more
like a flu I mean it's a it's obviously
got a significantly higher mortality
rate but still right now according to
all the experts the mortality rate is
about two percent not good but a lot
better than 98 percent right coronavirus
is related to other of the similar
viruses that we've seen like you
remember the SARS epidemic it's related
to SARS again not a good thing but the
whole world survived that 2% mortality
rate by the way is using data from the
epicenter of this epidemic at mainland
China so look it's obviously very
different than Ebola you've got to ask
yourself when you want to judge whether
this is a panic created for political
advantage or really we're all gonna die
or you know it's something in the middle
what could President Trump have said or
done that would have made the left happy
what could he have possibly said or done
in that press conference that wouldn't
have been twisted as the end of the
world who could he have appointed
they're all upset that he appointed Mike
Pence because Mike Pence I guess is the
cause of AIDS or something whatever the
left is saying today let's say he
appointed someone with medical
experience say you appointed Ben Carson
ben Carson what's the most celebrated
renowned surgeons in the United States
first guy to to successfully separate
conjoined twins who were conjoined at
the head if they had appointed Ben
Carson can you just imagine the
headlines today mocking Ben I mean
you're you don't need to imagine it you
can remember the 2016 race when they
called him an idiot when they called him
a sellout when they called him ignorant
right they can do that to a major
medical figure in the United States
they're gonna do it to anybody
what if president from shut down the
airports can you imagine the racism well
one time he did block people from coming
in who were in very dangerous countries
countries with a high terrorism problem
and whose pilloried is a racist a
monster a bigot they're still talking
about it on the campaign trail
what if President Trump had shut down
the border he said we got a global
pandemic we're gonna stop people who
might be infected from coming in here
well I'll tell you how the left would
have reacted because the Elizabeth
Warren already used this point and she
used it to make the dumbest political
argument that I've heard from the
Democratic presidential field in I don't
know twenty four hours or something I
obviously there's not huge timescales
here we'll get to that in a second first
I got to thank our friends over at We
the People holsters starting at just 37
dollars 37 dollars
we the people holsters are custom
designed to fit your firearm perfectly
and I mean perfectly they're also made
right here in the USA so they've got
thousands of options to choose from if
we're both inside and outside the
waistband they have an amazing selecting
a selection of printed holsters they got
everything from the Constitution to the
thin blue line they look really good
they're made for people of your and my
persuasion let's say their proprietary
clip design allows for you to adjust
easily both the can't and ride of your
holster so that it will fit comfortably
and securely at all times right now go
to we the people holsters comm slash
Knowles can or wles
and get yours today every holster ships
free and comes with a lifetime guarantee
you can get an additional $10 off with
the offer code Knowles Canada wles so
yeah it's already pretty cheap 37
dollars then you get it down to 27
dollars for the best holster that I
could possibly recommend to you
satisfaction guaranteed if it's not a
perfect fit send it back for a total
refund we the people holsters comm slash
Knowles Canada wles offer code Knowles
if Trump had done anything if he had
said anything if he had appointed
anybody the left would be freaking out
and saying it was the worst thing he
could have done one obvious thing
President Trump could do which he's been
trying to do since 2016 is get control
of the border get control of who enters
and exits the United States figure out
figure out who's coming into the United
States the the reason that we need to be
able to get control of the border is
because is exemplified when you've got a
global pandemic like this so what's the
argument the Democrats are making
Elizabeth Warren at a town hall that
apparently happened last night on CNN
nobody watched it nobody paid attention
we just can't take that much of them she
said that the first thing she would do
as president would be to take all the
money that President Trump is spending
on border security and put it toward
researching coronavirus I'm gonna be
introducing a plan tomorrow to take
every dime that the president is now
spending on his racist wall at our
southern border and divert it to work on
the corona virus great idea Liz that's
what you want when you've got a global
pandemic going on the first thing you
want to do is open up all the borders
and have no idea who's coming into your
country brilliant that's the kind of
Harvard education that we need to get
into the White House this is a major
problem I don't know if coronavirus is a
major problem it might be it might not
be as of right now it's very unclear the
major problem is that we can't trust the
media to tell us we do not know right
now if coronavirus is the second coming
or a later coming of the bubonic plague
or if it's just like the seasonal flu or
cold or something we don't know that
because our press is so corrupt our
press is so blindly opposed to this
president that we cannot trust them to
blow up something which is not a big
deal into a global panic to send markets
tanking all because they hate this
president I mean we've seen this time
and time again James O'Keefe from
project very test just busted an ABC
reporter for admitting that he's a
socialist right he came he was caught on
hidden tape it's all yeah I'm a total
socialist you BAM not even a democratic
socialist I'm just a full-on socialist
we've known this there's there's nothing
really shocking about that kind of a
report we we've known that about the
press for years but then they admit it
and you think oh that's right they all
have this political bias
and some are better at hiding it than
others
CNN's Jim Acosta demonstrated this
principle just the other day when he
flat-out insulted the president and a
news conference I just wanted to follow
up on my colleagues question about
Russian interference can you pledge to
the American people that you will not
accept any foreign assistance in the
upcoming election and on this idea of a
purge in your administration there was
recently the departure of your acting
DNI Joseph McGuire who replaced him with
your ambassador to Germany Rick Grinnell
some of your critics have pointed out
that ambassador Grinnell has no
intelligence experience how can you
justify to the American people having an
Acting DNI with no intelligence okay
okay okay excuse me first of all here so
he asks a fair question right by CNN
standards a fair question I'm not saying
it's a totally fair question but it's
you've got this guy Richard Grinnell who
is former ambassador to Germany he's was
I think the longest-serving spokesman
ever at the UN and then he's in this
acting position as the top spy then
President Trump turns it right to reveal
hold on this isn't a fair question
you're not coming from a place of good
faith he turns the question he puts it
back on Acosta no help from any country
and I haven't been given help from any
country and if you see what CNN your
wonderful Network said I guess they
apologized in a way for didn't they
apologize for the fact that they said
certain things that weren't care tell me
what was their apology yesterday what
did they say okay so you see what Trump
does here Trump knows that there's no
win by explaining why his acting DNI is
a real cool guy there's no win anyway he
does it he's on the defensive Acosta has
set up this sort of unfair situation
where Trump's got to defend a guy who's
got a unimpeachable resume so Trump
turns it on Acosta but he's using very
nice language she's usually very
diplomatic language so you know you at
your wonderful Network you know what you
guys always do to me
and he's needling acosta and he's
pushing Acosta to answer a question and
Acosta takes the bait as president I
think our record on delivering the truth
is a lot better than your some job I
don't mind me saying let me tell you
about your record your record is so bad
you ought to be ashamed of yourself ya
problem I'm not saying anything in our
probably it was not in the history of
broadcasting as far as Maguire is
concerned he's a terrific guy but you
know in March 11th his time ended anyway
so his time came up so we would have had
to by statute we would have had to
change him anyways so the new Z and I
have experienced I'd Intel yes in fact
we're talking to five different people
right now I think all people that you
know all people that you respect and
I'll make a decision probably over the
next week to two weeks we have some very
good people oh look at that masterful
exchange did you see what he did there
so he needles and he's pushing him he's
pushing him and then Jim Acosta
completely takes the bait and shows his
cards Trump was provoking Jim Acosta
here he was trying to get Jim Acosta to
show his corruption and bias but then
Jim Acosta did it right it is absent no
matter what the president says no matter
what the politician that you're
interviewing says it is absolutely not
the role of the reporter to start
insulting the politician oh actually we
have a much better record on truth than
you do you idiot you dumb I hate you I
hate you mr. president that's it's so
pathetic
Rick Chris Chris Wallace at Fox News who
is I believe he is a Democrat he said
off the record you know this has been
reported in some of the press that he
was so embarrassed by that answer I mean
what it what a humiliating answer for
the journalistic profession from Jim
Acosta there to just start insulting the
president but we know this right so what
President Trump does starts at it's a
sort of fair question then Jim Acosta
reveals that he's just an anti-trump
operative and then at the end you saw a
president Trump turns it again it starts
giving a real answer he says now you
know look but we're gonna interview some
good people we got all people I think
you're really going to like so
the book ends the beginning in the end
of Trump's performance look really good
and in the middle what President Trump
did was get the press to reveal how much
they hate him
that tarnishes their credibility that's
their fault that they're doing it
they're the ones giving up their
credibility so now we can't even know if
we're all gonna die from coronavirus or
if it's it's really no big deal moving
on to the 2020 race we also don't really
know what's going on there because we're
getting a lot of conflicting polls Joe
Biden we thought was down and at him
he's pretty much just muttering to
himself onstage at the last debate and
yet all hope might not be lost for Joe
because there is a new poll that's come
out from Clemson as a poll came out
yesterday Joe Biden according to this
poll has an 18 point lead in South
Carolina the the numbers are Biden 35%
steyr 17% you forgot that guy was even
in the race Sanders 13% Warren and Budaj
edged 8% club you char 4% that is a very
sizable lead for Joe Biden which means
that Biden actually might be back in
this race on top of that Mike Bloomberg
is stalling so right now after his very
poor debate performances it looks as
though his national polls have stalled
out or they've actually begun to reverse
themselves in California right now
Bloomberg is back down at 11% in Super
Tuesday states he's he's down he's in
the teens and he's in the low 20s that's
not enough to take him to the nomination
so Bernie our Biden rather might have
the moderate lane this is causing a lot
of Republicans to vote for Bernie
Sanders and I don't mean they're just
rooting for Bernie Sanders I mean they
are going out in the open primaries
where Republicans can vote for Democrats
and voting for Bernie Sanders there's
actually a video that was leaked from
some Trump supporters that came at
yesterday the never Trump Republicans
are all upset about this this came out
yesterday where these mischievous
Republicans were arguing all of their
for all of their fellow Republicans to
go out and vote for Bernie in the
nomination so that Trump can clobber him
in November
supporter President Trump are you a
registered voter in South Carolina hi
I'm Karen with Spartanburg Tea Party and
I'm Stacy a grassroots activist South
Carolina Republicans have waited since
2016 to vote again for president Trump
with no Republican primary in South
Carolina voters will have to wait until
November to cast a vote for our
president but there's still away South
Carolina Republicans can support
president Trump even after losing in
Iowa and New Hampshire Joe Biden is
still the favorite in South Carolina we
all know that the DNC in the Democrat
establishment do not want the
independent senator from Vermont as
their nominee we're asking South
Carolina Republicans to show their
support for President Trump by crossing
over and voting in the Democratic
primary for senator Bernie Sanders we
feel this may help move the needle in
closing our primaries in South Carolina
help us help President Trump by going to
your polling location on Saturday
February 29th and voting for independent
Bernie Sanders to be the Democrat
nominee what have I been telling you
I've been telling you to do exactly the
same thing and I'm so glad that they are
backing me up on this some of the never
Trump Republicans bill kristol in
particular was posting this around we're
saying that this is terrible nefarious
it's a smoking gun this is perfectly
legal
this isn't violating any laws people do
this all the time whether or not it
actually affects elections I'm a little
more skeptical of that it's hard enough
to get people to come out and vote for
their own party to get them to go
re-register go show up to another
primary I don't think it actually works
that much but I understand why these
Republicans want Bernie to get the
nomination because I do think
increasingly it's likely that Trump will
sweep them all now if the economy
totally tanks I guess it's anybody's
ballgame so there is some risk
especially as coronavirus is going
around but even so I don't think that
America is ready to vote for a very
elderly socialist so that's the one kind
of Republican that is voting for Bernie
Sanders there is another kind of
Republican voting for Bernie Sanders and
if you think that the logic of those Tea
Party activists is a little kooky just
wait until you hear the illage
of the never Trump Republicans there is
an op-ed right now in The Washington
Post by Joe Walsh I I know Joe Walsh
he's always been nice to me I've
interviewed him on the radio but Joe
Walsh has lost it a little bit he's gone
off the deep end he was a major he
actually supported Trump in 2016 then he
became sort of the never Trump
Republican he ran for president he just
dropped out Joe Walsh writes this piece
quote I'm no fan of Bernie Sanders but
never Trump means never Trump sorry GOP
outcasts but sometimes Trump just
doesn't cut it now Joe actually want to
read right below the byline it says Joe
Walsh is a former Illinois congressman
and the author of f they spell it all
out
silence calling Trump out for the
cultish moronic authoritarian con man he
is which I love that I say I I hate that
this effing Trump is so effing vulgar I
hate that he's such a name-calling [ __ ]
jerk you know it's art you're sort of
doing the things you're accusing him of
doing but anyway this is his logic and
it shows you the moral error that is at
the the heart not just of never Trump
but of any political position that backs
you into an untenable corner he writes
quote this isn't complicated never Trump
has always been a straightforward
concept the word never is right there in
the name but with senator Bernie Sanders
moving ahead of the pack as the clear
front-runner in this year's Democratic
presidential primaries some of my
Republican and ex Republican brethren
have started implying that what never
Trump actually meant was something more
like fingers crossed I really really
hope not Trump but I guess sometimes
Trump if Democrats wind up nominating a
self-described Democratic Socialist but
that's not how it works when I finally
came around to saying never Trump I
meant it never Trump means that you
still believe in the Constitution it
means you knew what Benjamin Franklin
meant when he warned that we Americans
have been blessed with a republic if you
can keep it
it means you recognize that Trump is
enough of a threat to our founding
principles that you won't vote
under any circumstances and at least to
me it also means you'll suck it up and
support his Democrat opponent no matter
who that is no do you know what it means
it means you made a mistake and you're
too prideful to admit it
that's what never Trump means today I'm
not saying that's what never Trump meant
in 2016 there were a lot of open
questions about President Trump but
today never Trump means that you made a
mistake you made a miscalculation
circumstances were not as you predicted
and they actually worked out pretty well
but you have too much pride to admit
that you were wrong never Trump means
you still believe in the Constitution
first of all the never Trump forces have
been consistently undermining the
Constitution since before the 2016
election to try to get that guy removed
from office extra constitutionally
Benjamin Franklin warned Americans do
you you think that Benjamin Franklin
would prefer an America hating America
blaming socialists like Bernie Sanders
over Donald Trump what because Donald
Trump has sort of boorish behavior have
you ever read about Benjamin Franklin do
you know how that man behaved have you
read his autobiography use a little bit
of a libertine sometimes okay come on
under eye means you won't vote under any
circumstances it means you'll vote for a
socialist I guess that is what it means
even he actually says it right here in
the article I hate to break it to you
but if you really never Trump then you
know there's no except if he's a
socialist footnote so then what's it
about because I thought the good
argument for for not voting for Trump if
you were conservative in 2016
was that you thought he would be more
left-wing than Hillary Clinton was that
a convincing argument no but there was a
possibility there he had donated to a
lot of Democrats he had described him
described himself as very very
pro-choice there was a real fear that he
was this left-wing guy and that if you
had a left-wing guy take over the
Republican Party that would be very bad
and so we don't want to do that okay I
get that argument it's something to it
but if the only argument for never Trump
is that you don't like the mean tweets
you think he's he doesn't talk right you
think he's a little too boorish and then
you're willing to vote for a socialist
instead you have completely lost the
narrative you've completely lost the
point of politics it has just become for
you about manners about a kind of
performance but it's not about the real
substantive issues underneath Trump has
been the most conservative president not
only in my lifetime probably the most
conservative president since Calvin
Coolidge it's pretty good can't you take
a win if you're willing to vote for a
socialist over that were you ever a
conservative in the first place maybe
you were but certainly what has happened
to you is you have been so warped by
pride that you your view of politics is
now uh Turley unreliable look just very
quickly before we get to the mailbag
there was a progressive think tanks
analysis that just came out over
Bernie's plans this is it's actually
called the progressive Policy Institute
Bernie's plans would cost over 10 years
you know how much 50 trillion dollars
with 80 the federal budget is four and a
half trillion each year this would
double the size of the government of the
federal government it would cost fifteen
trillion dollars more over ten years
than the next most radical candidate
which is Elizabeth Warren and it would
cost 42 trillion dollars more than the
third most expensive Democratic
candidate mayor Pete Buddha judge now I
actually don't think that kind of
accounting matters all that much because
I think for most people you hear a big
number and you say all big numbers are
the same yeah it's a really really big
number it's something ten dozen Ilya
iliyan all right it's bean-counting you
don't win arguments from bean-counting
especially not to beat a guy like Bernie
Sanders who's making moral arguments
okay you've got to make the moral
arguments yourself Elizabeth Warren made
this mistake the other night she said
look I love Bernie's policies but I'm
gonna implement them better I'm I'll
implement them more efficiently nobody
votes for efficiency nobody votes for a
better manager that doesn't razz you and
send you to the polls we're voting for a
cause we're voting for a vision all
right the argument again
socialism has to be moral and if you're
or if you're just making arguments from
bean-counting or efficiency if you're
making arguments because of how you
don't like the guy's tweets you've lost
the narrative and you need to get
serious we need to get serious too into
this mailbag but first I got to say
goodbye to Facebook and YouTube first
before we go go bye Matt Walsh's book
Church of cowards very important book
right now you've got Christians being
martyred in the Middle East
you've got Christians in America who
aren't even willing to voice their
opinion because they're afraid of not
getting invited to a few parties or
something Church of cowards go get it
you can get it at Amazon Barnes and
Noble anywhere that you get fine fine
conservative books Super Tuesday leave
that night open we will be with you
smoking stogies drinking too much
whiskey and following the results all
night we will be there and set your
clock for many many hours we're gonna be
doing all of that and then by the way on
leap day which comes around once every
four years head over to the daily wire
we've got a very very special deal
coming for you so you're not gonna want
to miss that because if you miss it
it's gonna take another four years and
by then I think global warming will have
done us in there'll be a lot of there
will be a lot of world problems so make
sure you get it now daily wired.com
we'll be right back with the mailbag
first question from Golda dear mr. Noles
what is the difference between love and
infatuation how can I tell if he is the
one thank you what a brilliant question
this is something that people no longer
understand because we use stupid slogans
like love is love as though that tells
us anything about politics or love or
philosophy or ourselves there is a big
difference between love and infatuation
infatuation another term for that would
be sentimentality it's like it's like
that real sugary Hallmark card II kind
of love but it's not really love
infatuation is all about you love is all
about the other person so we all knew
this person when we were in school there
is a girl who just always needed to have
a boyfriend
and whatever boyfriend she had was
always like the greatest guy in the
world he had all the greatest qualities
and he was just like he's a hero he was
a god right and then they would break up
and she get a new boyfriend and then the
new boyfriend was exactly the same thing
it's because with infatuation what you
are doing is you are really in love with
the idea of being in love you are really
in love with an ideal that you have
created in your own mind of the perfect
person and then whether or not the
person in reality matches up to that
person you are superimposing all of
those ideals onto the person so it's
it's a totally six circular thing you
are you are simply in love with your own
self-generated idea love true love is
willing the good of the other person so
true love is warts and all true love is
staring the other person in the face
seeing them for who they are in reality
and loving that person anyway or maybe
because of that big difference make sure
that you are you're really loving the
other person and it's not just the
images that you're putting on that
person in one way to know that to know
the difference is to analyze other
relationships that you've had
if they've all had the same kind of
character if if you've all kind of
viewed the person in exactly the same
way you might be dealing with
infatuation but if you really like the
other guy then it's probably love from
Eric the excellent Michael Knowles one
theme of your show is how the modern
left rejects the concept of objective
morality I've noticed the ones rejection
of objective morality quickly follows
their rejection of God so my question
for you is can one believe an objective
morality without believing in God
moreover how can we as conservatives
argue for objective morality without
tracing said morality back to God thanks
one can believe in objective morality
with without God it's just that one
would be wrong you know we believe all
sorts of things that don't make a whole
lot of sense and so you can do that but
it doesn't make any sense there cannot
be objective morality without God
actually one of the arguments for God's
existence is the argument from morality
very simply if morality is objective and
absolute which is what we mean when we
say morality or objective morality then
God must exist now there are a couple
ways this can go if you're an atheist
great many atheists or materialists so
they'd say everything that we talk about
that really matters to us love hopes
dreams joy they're all an illusion
they're all just something we're fooling
ourselves with all that really exists is
flesh and bones and we got chemicals
firing off in our brains and that's
what's giving us this impression of a
metaphysical reality if that's the kind
of atheism we're talking about then then
morality can't exist at all because
morality is not a physical thing you
can't hold on to it and touch it it's a
metaphysical thing that doesn't work now
if you're the sort of atheist who says
you know hey man I'm not religious but
I'm spiritual or something like that
some kind of vague notion of
spirituality which usually just means
I'm not that interested in God but I'm
really interested in myself if you've
got that kind of idea okay listen I
don't mean to make fun of this I
actually held that view myself once when
I was a teenager but if you have that
idea then I guess a morality could exist
why
the idea that through evolution human
beings have for some reason developed
these highly sophisticated systems of
morality which often encourage us to
sacrifice ourselves she doesn't seem to
bode very well for evolution but it's
evolved somehow in any way it's always
changing because humans are always
evolving
that is a morality but that is not an
objective absolute morality right
because it's always changing it's always
constructed by human beings if we all
came together and came up with a
different idea then that would be the
morality if you want the objective
absolute morality which is all anybody
is referring to when we when we use that
term God must exist and that's a
wonderful thing from Matt hey Michael
who is fact-checking these debate
moderators I feel like there was a lot
of misinformation directed into the
questions the one that stood out to me
was the African Americans earning 73
cents on the dollar compared to white
Americans statistic where is the
evidence to support this
these moderators present the candidates
these statistics as and the candidates
present these statistics as facts and
that's wrong Thanks that statistic the
73 cents on the dollar for that black
Americans are in compared to white
Americans I looked this one up and it is
a real statistic it comes from Pew
Research you see it post around from
fairly reputable sources the problem
with the moderators and the candidates
is not that they're presenting these
statistics the problem is they're not
explaining these statistics so they
present a statistics for that context
and then they use that to imply that
they're the reason that there's this
wage gap is because of systemic racism
institutionalized racism but that isn't
the case the reason that there's that
wage gap is not explained primarily by
race it's explained primarily by
education and experience in the
workforce the race is not the primary
factor it's not really much of a factor
at all the real factor here is you've
got different educational attainment
you've got different schools you've got
different time in the workforce you've
got different caliber of work at you
know different companies and so when you
wash all
if you look at it primarily through the
lens of race there's this wage gap but
it's not evidence of racism it's the
same thing with the gender wage gap
there's a similar wage gap between men
and women men of all races and women of
all races and it they say women earn
seventy-five cents on the dollar that
men do which is true until you correct
for education and time in the workforce
when you correct for that just like the
racial wage gap the wage gap disappears
now obviously the Democrats are not
going to present that context because
they want to race hustle and sex hustle
to try to divide Americans and get their
votes and the moderators are not going
to rekt them on it because the
moderators are Democrats too from Sarah
dear most revered and austere religious
podcaster I love your shows and have two
questions thank you very much first what
are you listening to in your earpiece
during the Michael Noel's show secondly
what do you and Ted Cruz talked about on
verdict when the cameras and microphones
aren't recording thanks so in my
earpiece during the show I'm I'm
listening to Hall & Oates and when I'm
speaking to Ted Cruz during verdict and
the cameras are off and the microphones
are off we're talking about what's
really going on at area 51 and I wish
that I could tell you but if I told you
I would have to kill you from Grant hi
Michael I recently finished a bunch of
CS Lewis's work Screwtape Letters mere
christianity in the great divorce and
i'm currently reading Chesterton's
orthodoxy after this I'm looking to
delve into Dante's Divine Comedy what a
great reading list you've got however
I'm not sure which translation of Dante
to pick up do you have a recommendation
thank you cheers to 500 more episodes I
would recommend and I'm only giving this
at secondhand the John chardee
translation I have not read a
translation of it because when I was
growing up for some reason I thought it
would be a good idea to learn Italian
which is possibly the least practically
useful language in the world so I didn't
learn Spanish I didn't learn a language
they could actually get me around you
know day to day but I did learn Italian
so that's how I read Dante but I would
recommend the chardy
because friends of mine who have have
read both say the chardee is very good
from Chris
hello mr. Knowles the more science and
medicine progressive progressives the
more we realize our thoughts and
sometimes our actions are a function of
hormones and our body's chemical
processes I know we have the ability to
overcome these chemicals and hormones
but I can't quite wrap my brain around
reconciling that with the idea of free
will thanks and don't let Ben push you
out you're the real star there
thank you very much Wow listen to what
you wrote though in that question the
question that you wrote actually kind of
gives away the misunderstanding here you
said I can't quite wrap my brain around
it now the usual phrase is I can't quite
wrap my mind around it and the
difference is the brain is a physical
organ and the mind is is your sort of
intellectual metaphysical thing but what
you're saying is yeah I'm kind of
doubting that the metaphysical exists I
think we're all just a product of our
chemicals I just kind of reject the
premise here I don't think that medical
science shows us that our choices are or
merely or primarily the effect of
physical processes that are going on
here's how I know this if you've ever
learned anything at all you know that
learning is not the effect of merely
physical processes so the biggest
transformations that we could possibly
undergo in our minds or our brains I
guess is learning right because we're
changing your mind right so you've got
one idea and then something new happens
and you change it that could be radical
I mean it can have major effects on how
you live your life if you're a got real
decadent guy and you're going out to the
strip club every night and getting
bottle service and then you change your
mind you read a book you read the Bible
and you say oh my gosh I've got to go
become a monk in the hills you have just
done a very physical level completely
change the way that your life is gonna
go but it wasn't caused by a physical
process it was caused by an intellectual
and metaphysical process right you've
read something you've taken in that
information that has led to physical
changes the reason people get confused
about this is because the only thing we
can see is the physical so they're
confusing correlation for causation
they're saying because I can see that
there's a physical change here
the physical has to be the cause of it
but actually we we are not merely our
bodies and we're also not merely our
spirits that's another ancient heresy
that was condemned a long time ago this
idea that the body is evil and it's fake
it's actually coming back now in the
form of transgenderism which tells you
that your body has no bearing on who you
are and really you're just a you're a
secret invisible being and and you've
got to change your body to get in line
with that actually we're both we're body
and soul
we were mind spirit right roll all in
this one human unity and and we do have
free will it's not something that you
can see but you can't see most of the
things that matter in your life all
right let's get to the last question
here from Ryan dear Michael what would
you recommend for my first cigar thanks
PS I miss getting episodes of another
Kingdom thanks for bringing that work to
life very important question very
important question the first cigar my
first cigar was a was a Cuban cigar was
given to me by a friend if I were you
your round here I would start out with
something like the Oliva series Oh
or the Q's ah no 18 or it's a cigar
they're a little bit more mild kind of
get you into and then you can graduate
to more intense flavor profiles alright
that's our show we have so much more to
get to but I can't because I've got to
run over to CPAC CPAC is going on right
now in Washington DC that's why I'm
broadcasting from this hotel room
because senator Ted Cruz and I are going
to be doing an episode of verdict live
at CPAC with the chairwoman Ronnie
McDaniel of the Republican National
Committee it's going to be a whole lot
of fun we got more more surprises coming
up there so if you're in DC head on over
and say hello otherwise I'll see you
next week I'm Michael Knowles this is
the Michael Nolt show
[Music]
the Michael Nolt show is produced by Ben
Davies and directed by Mike joiner
executive producer Jeremy borin
supervising producers Mathis Glover and
Robert Stirling technical producer
Austin Stephens assistant director hovel
Woodhouse key editor and associate
producer Danny D'Amico audio mixer Robin
Fenderson hair and makeup Nika Geneva
production assistant Ryan love the
Michael Knowles show is a daily wire
production copyright daily wire 20 20 if
you prefer facts over feelings aren't
offended by the brutal truth and you can
still laugh at the insanity filling our
national news cycle well tune in to the
Ben Shapiro show we'll get a whole lot
of that and much more see you there